- Ласкаво просимо назад до курсу «Розуміння квантової
інформації та обчислень».
Мене звати John Watrous, я технічний директор
з освіти в IBM Quantum.
Це другий урок серії. Якщо ти ще не
переглядав перший урок, обов'язково подивись його.
Ми будемо безпосередньо спиратися на те, про що говорили
на першому уроці, тому важливо розуміти
той матеріал, перш ніж переходити до цього уроку.
Також майте на увазі, що серія
включає текстовий матеріал на додаток до відео, і посилання
на текстовий матеріал можна знайти
в описі відео. Це другий урок
першого розділу серії.
Перший розділ охоплює основи
квантової інформації.
На попередньому уроці ми говорили про квантову інформацію в контексті одиночних систем, тобто коли є одна
система, що зберігає інформацію,
і ми описуємо, як
вона працює ізольовано.
Ми приділили чимало уваги
класичній інформації — головним чином для того, щоб встановити точку відліку та підкреслити математичну схожість
між квантовою та класичною інформацією.
Ми також побачили, як квантові стани можна представляти векторами — зокрема, векторами з
комплексними числами як елементами та евклідовою нормою, рівною одиниці,
і ми обговорили вимірювання у
стандартному базисі та унітарні операції.
На цьому уроці ми розширимо наш
погляд до кількох систем, кожна з яких здатна
зберігати квантову інформацію.
Це не просто питання твердження про те, що кожна окрема система
працює так, як ми обговорювали минулого разу, — є певний сенс, в якому ціле
більше, ніж сума частин, і це справедливо також для
класичної інформації, коли задіяні ймовірності.
Кілька систем можуть
взаємодіяти одна з одною та бути корельованими
одна з одною, наприклад, і в квантовому контексті це включає можливість
того, що системи заплутані — це термін, який ти,
можливо, вже чув раніше.
Заплутаність — це дуже
важливе явище в квантовій інформації, і ми ще багато про нього скажемо в міру продовження серії.
Існує простий принцип, який дає нам чимало підстав для роздумів та
розуміння квантової інформації для кількох систем,
і полягає він у тому, що ми завжди можемо
взяти дві або більше систем і поєднати їх, або просто концептуально
думати про них разом,
і розглядати їх так, ніби вони утворюють
єдину складену систему.
І коли ми думаємо про таку
складену систему, як про єдину систему, ми визнаємо, що вона має бути описана способом, який узгоджується
з усім, що ми дізналися
на попередньому уроці про одиночні системи.
Ми побачимо, як це працює,
і як опис квантової інформації
для кількох систем досить природно випливає з того, як це працює для одиночних систем,
спираючись на цей єдиний принцип. Ось огляд уроку, і він випадково збігається з оглядом попереднього уроку,
але цього разу наш фокус
буде на кількох системах, а не на одиночних.
Так само, як ми робили на попередньому уроці та з тих самих причин, ми почнемо з
класичної інформації.
Знову ж таки, ми побачимо
дуже тісну схожість між тим, як квантова
та класична інформація працюють на математичному рівні.
Зазвичай ми не будемо так
сильно зосереджуватись на класичній інформації і починати кожен урок серії з класичної інформації подібним чином.
Подальші уроки будуть зосереджені значно більш виключно на квантовій інформації та обчисленнях.
Але тут, на початку,
це розумний підхід, і він повертається до ідеї, що роздуми про класичну інформацію
можуть служити цінним джерелом орієнтирів для розуміння квантової інформації.
Ми також обговоримо
важливу концепцію тензорного добутку в
цій частині уроку.
Тензорні добутки критично важливі в квантовій інформації, але вони виникають і в
класичному контексті.
Потім ми перейдемо до квантової інформації і, так само як на попередньому уроці, обговоримо квантові стани,
вимірювання у стандартному базисі,
та унітарні операції — цього разу
для кількох систем.
Почнемо з розмови
про класичні стани кількох систем.
Пригадай з попереднього
уроку, що класичний стан системи — це
конфігурація цієї системи, яку можна розпізнати та
описати однозначно,
без будь-якої невизначеності чи помилки. У математичних термінах, коли ми говоримо про множину класичних станів,
ми просто маємо на увазі скінченну та непорожню множину.
Ми почнемо наше обговорення
кількох систем із припущення, що у нас є
лише дві системи X та Y.
X має деяку множину класичних станів, яку ми називемо сигма — так само
як на попередньому уроці, і Y має деяку множину класичних станів,
яку ми назвемо гамма. Множини сигма та гамма
можуть бути однаковою множиною або різними,
але ми даємо їм різні назви не лише тому, що
вони можуть бути різними множинами, але й тому, що це допоможе
нам зберігати чіткість, якщо ми даємо їм різні назви.
Ми побачимо, що досить
легко узагальнити всю цю дискусію від двох систем до будь-якої їх кількості, але
починаючи з двох систем,
ми можемо зосередитись на фундаментальних ідеях, не загрузаючи в деталях.
WEBVTT
Тепер уяви, що ми
поставили X та Y поряд — X зліва, а Y справа, і розглядаємо ці дві системи разом
так, ніби вони утворюють єдину складену систему.
Щоб дати назву цій новій системі, ми можемо написати її як
впорядковану пару ось так, або просто поставити
дві літери поряд ось так.
Обидва варіанти поширені, і ми можемо
обрати той, який хочемо або який зручніший.
В будь-якому випадку ми читатимемо це як XY.
Дуже природне питання,
яке варто поставити тут, — які є класичні стани цієї нової складеної системи XY?
І відповідь на це питання така: множина класичних станів XY є декартовим добутком
двох множин класичних станів,
сигма та гамма, що можна
побачити ось тут.
У кожен момент часу X перебуває в якомусь класичному стані,
що є елементом сигма, а Y перебуває в якомусь класичному стані,
що є елементом гамма,
і ми просто думаємо
про ці два стани разом, ніби вони утворюють єдиний стан — і саме це поняття
і відображає декартовий добуток. Ми маємо два елементи,
по одному з кожної нашої множини, і хочемо думати про
ці два елементи разом,
ніби вони утворюють єдиний
елемент єдиної множини.
Щоб бути точним, тут є припущення: ми знаємо,
яка з наших систем є X, а яка — Y,
і між ними немає плутанини. Не важливо, що X фізично знаходиться зліва,
а Y — справа,
а важливо те, що дві
системи розрізняються, і ми вирішили
впорядкувати їх саме так, щоб чітко розуміти, яка є яка.
Ось дуже простий приклад, де сигма — двійковий алфавіт, а гамма — множина,
що містить чотири масті карт.
Якщо X зберігає двійкове значення, а Y зберігає одну з чотирьох мастей карт, то існує вісім
можливих класичних станів
пари XY, які
можна побачити перерахованими тут.
Для більш ніж двох систем це узагальнюється у прямолінійний спосіб.
Зокрема, якщо X1 до Xn — системи, що мають множини класичних станів
сигма один до сигма n відповідно,
то якщо ми уявимо об'єднання
n систем і розглядатимемо їх як одну систему, множина класичних станів
задається декартовим добутком
n множин класичних станів
сигма один до сигма n.
Як бачиш тут на екрані. Декартовий добуток
можна визначити ось так для будь-якої кількості множин.
Наприклад, якщо ми маємо три системи і всі вони використовують двійковий алфавіт як свою множину класичних станів, — тобто, іншими словами, ми маємо три біти, —
то існує вісім
можливих класичних станів трьох бітів, що розглядаються
разом як єдина система, і ти можеш побачити їх перерахованими тут.
Кожна система окремо може
перебувати у стані нуль або один, і ми перебираємо всі
можливі комбінації.
n-кортеж класичних станів можна альтернативно записати у вигляді рядка, де ми прибираємо
дужки та кому, як показано тут.
І це особливо зручно, коли ми думаємо про
класичні стани як символи — як у дуже поширеному прикладі
двійкового алфавіту,
до якого ми постійно повертаємось. Іноді це дуже зручно, і це робить
наші вирази простішими
та менш громіздкими. Поняття рядка, власне, формалізується
в математичних термінах через декартові добутки,
тому це насправді просто
альтернативне позначення, а не щось концептуально інше.
Для прикладу, скажімо, що ми маємо
10 бітів X1 до X10.
Це означає, що множина класичних станів 10 бітів разом,
яку ти, мабуть, природно мислиш як 10-бітний регістр
у комп'ютері, наприклад,
є десятикратним декартовим
добутком двійкового алфавіту з самим собою.
І якщо ми записуємо ці стани як рядки, вони виглядають, як бачиш тут: їх 1024,
тому, звісно, вони тут усі не перераховані. Ці три крапки тут
мають означати, що є певна закономірність, яку ти можеш вивести,
і сподіваємось, ти розумієш ідею. Є певна угода,
якої ми будемо дотримуватись для впорядкування елементів
множин декартового добутку,
і важливо
прояснити її заради представлення як імовірнісних станів, так і квантових станів у вигляді векторів.
Угода полягає в тому, що
ми впорядковуємо елементи множин декартового добутку лексикографічно, що по суті означає словниковий порядок.
Якщо бути точнішим, ми починаємо з припущення, що кожна з окремих множин, декартовий добуток яких ми беремо, вже має своє власне впорядкування,
і думаємо про
даний n-кортеж або рядок, ніби це слово, і впорядковуємо їх в алфавітному порядку.
Іншими словами, позиції в
n-кортежі або рядку зменшуються за значущістю зліва направо,
так само як коли ми записуємо числа за допомогою цифр від нуля до дев'яти.
Ось приклад, який
має прояснити це.
Якщо ми беремо декартовий добуток між множинами, що містять
один, два та три, і двійковим алфавітом, ми отримуємо множину з шести елементів,
і тут вони перераховані в
описаному порядку.
Всі елементи з
одиницею на першій позиції стоять перед усіма елементами з двійкою на першій позиції, а ті — перед усіма елементами
WEBVTT
з трійкою на першій позиції. І коли два елементи
збігаються на першій позиції, ми спираємось на впорядкування
на другій позиції.
Ось таке впорядкування
ми використовуємо для декартових добутків.
Зауваж, що коли ми використовуємо цю угоду і записуємо n-кортежі як рядки, ми спостерігаємо деякі дуже знайомі закономірності.
Наприклад, декартовий добуток
двійкового алфавіту з самим собою впорядкований, як бачиш тут,
і ти можеш думати про ці рядки як упорядковані числово, якщо розглядати ці рядки
як двійкові кодування невід'ємних цілих чисел — і це узагальнюється
до рядків будь-якої довжини. Переходячи до імовірнісних станів, ми вже знаємо з попереднього уроку,
що імовірнісний стан пов'язує ймовірність з кожним класичним
станом даної системи.
Якщо ми маємо складену систему, де ми взяли дві або більше систем і розглядаємо їх колективно, ніби вони утворюють єдину
систему, як щойно обговорювали,
то імовірнісний стан
цієї складеної системи повинен присвоювати ймовірності елементам декартового добутку
окремих систем,
множин класичних станів. Це тому, що саме вона є
множиною класичних станів складеної системи.
Наприклад, припустимо,
що X та Y — це біти; ось приклад
імовірнісного стану XY.
Ймовірність того, що обидва
біти рівні нулю, становить одну другу, і ймовірність того, що обидва
біти рівні одиниці, теж становить одну другу, тому два біти ніколи не розходяться.
Це валідний імовірнісний стан XY, і ми можемо альтернативно
записати його як вектор,
як бачиш тут, і тут можна побачити, що ми
дотримуємось угоди, яку я щойно описав, для впорядкування цих класичних станів.
Це приклад
імовірнісного стану, де X та Y корельовані, і в цьому сенс того, що ціле
більше, ніж сума частин. Як я зазначив раніше, це не просто те, що ми
маємо імовірнісний стан
X та імовірнісний стан Y і складаємо їх разом, а швидше ми спочатку об'єднуємо
системи разом,
а потім думаємо про
імовірнісні стани складеної системи.
Щоб бути точнішим щодо
кореляцій між системами, ми починаємо з визначення поняття незалежності, що по суті є
відсутністю кореляції.
Тут, до речі, термін «незалежність» означає
статистичну незалежність, на відміну від лінійної незалежності
векторів, наприклад.
Це фундаментальне поняття в
теорії ймовірностей та статистиці.
Якщо ми маємо дві системи X та Y і маємо на увазі деякий імовірнісний
стан XY, то ми кажемо, що X та Y незалежні,
якщо формула, яку
ти бачиш тут, справедлива для кожного вибору класичних
станів a та b систем X та Y.
Один спосіб інтерпретувати цю
умову незалежності полягає в тому, що вона говорить: ймовірність того, що X перебуває в будь-якому класичному стані,
і ймовірність того, що Y перебуває в якомусь іншому класичному стані, абсолютно не пов'язані
одна з одною.
Тобто дізнавшись, в якому стані
перебуває одна із систем, це не впливає на
ймовірності, пов'язані зі станами іншої системи.
Якщо уявити, що ти навмання обираєш
якийсь класичний стан X відповідно до певної процедури, а потім навмання обираєш
якийсь класичний стан Y
відповідно до якоїсь іншої процедури, ніяк не пов'язаної з процедурою для X, — скажімо, якщо одна людина підкидає монету,
а інша людина в
іншій кімнаті кидає кубик, — то це та формула,
яку ти використовував би для отримання ймовірностей
для різних комбінацій
станів. Суть визначення в тому, що незалежність — це
коли формула є справедливою.
Коли ми думаємо про імовірнісні стани в термінах векторів ймовірностей, є проста формулювання
цієї умови,
а саме: якщо ми маємо
імовірнісний стан XY, який можна виразити як
вектор у дірак-позначенні,
як бачиш тут, то сказати, що X та Y незалежні, рівнозначно існуванню
двох векторів ймовірностей,
|Phi⟩ та |Psi⟩ — до речі, ми можемо
просто читати їх як «Фі» та «Псі» для стислості, — що представляють
імовірнісні стани X та Y окремо та задовольняють цю рівність,
яку ти бачиш тут.
Для всіх виборів a та b це, по суті,
переформулювання визначення в термінах векторів.
Наприклад, ось імовірнісний
стан пари бітів XY, для якого X та Y незалежні.
Умова, необхідна
для незалежності, є справедливою для векторів,
які ти бачиш тут.
Тобто ймовірність
для кожного можливого стану двох бітів задається добутком відповідних ймовірностей
для окремих бітів.
Наприклад, ймовірність того, що обидва
біти мають значення нуль, дорівнює одній шостій, що дорівнює одній
четвертій помноженій на дві третини,
і так само для
інших трьох можливостей, що можна перевірити по одній.
Для імовірнісного стану, який ми бачили раніше, де
ми маємо два біти, що завжди збігаються і приймають значення нуль та
одиницю з ймовірністю одна друга,
у нас немає незалежності, і тому ми кажемо, що
біти корельовані.
Кореляція просто означає
відсутність незалежності.
Простий спосіб довести, що
два біти не є незалежними, — припустити, що вони є, і отримати суперечність.
Зокрема, якщо два
біти були б незалежними, мали б існувати
числа q0, q1, r0 та r1
WEBVTT
що представляють ймовірності
для двох окремих бітів, так щоб ці рівняння,
наведені тут, виконувались.
Це ймовірності,
що походять з нашого вектора, і це рівняння, які мають виконуватись за умовою незалежності,
але якщо ми подивимось на цю
другу рівність тут, ми бачимо, що вона вимагає, щоб
q0 помножена на r1 дорівнювала нулю,
але єдиний спосіб, щоб
добуток двох дійсних чисел міг дорівнювати нулю, — це якщо принаймні одне з цих
чисел саме по собі дорівнює нулю.
Це іноді називають
властивістю нульового добутку дійсних чисел.
Іншими словами, добуток двох ненульових дійсних
чисел завжди є ненульовим.
Тому ця рівність тут
означає, що або q0 дорівнює нулю, або r1 дорівнює нулю,
але з першої та останньої рівностей ми бачимо, що жодна з
цих двох альтернатив не може бути справжньою.
Якщо q0 дорівнює нулю, то цей добуток мав би дорівнювати нулю, але він не дорівнює нулю,
і якщо r1 дорівнює нулю,
то цей добуток мав би дорівнювати нулю, але це теж не так.
Отже, ми маємо суперечність
і приходимо до висновку, що X та Y не є незалежними, тобто вони корельовані.
Поняття незалежності,
яке ми щойно обговорили, і зокрема його формулювання в термінах векторів
ймовірностей, тісно пов'язане
з операцією над векторами, відомою як тензорний добуток.
Тензорні добутки можна
визначати не лише для векторів, але й для матриць,
і насправді поняття тензорного добутку можна визначити
і для багатьох інших видів
математичних об'єктів.
Їх можна описати
досить абстрактно, що є важливим і
корисним у чистій математиці, але ми також можемо визначати
тензорні добутки для векторів
дуже просто та конкретно, і саме цей шлях
ми оберемо на цьому уроці.
Якщо ми маємо два стовпчикових вектори Phi та Psi, записаних у формах, які ти бачиш тут, де сигма та гамма — будь-який
вибір множин класичних станів,
або індексів, якщо завгодно, то тензорний добуток цих векторів — це вектор, який ти бачиш тут.
Ми перебираємо всі елементи
декартового добутку двох множин, сигма та гамма, і елемент цього
вектора, що відповідає
кожній парі ab, яка
записується як рядок тут, дорівнює добутку відповідних елементів
цих двох векторів. Іншими словами, елемент ab вектора Phi тензор Psi є добутком елемента a
вектора Phi та елемента b вектора Psi,
і це зміст
того, що записано тут.
По суті, це та сама операція, яку ми щойно бачили кілька хвилин тому, коли обговорювали незалежність,
і тепер ми просто даємо їй назву.
Ось той самий приклад,
який ми бачили хвилину тому, записаний більш явно в
термінах тензорного добутку.
Знову ж таки, ми маємо, що одна шоста дорівнює одній четвертій, помноженій на одну третю, одна дванадцята дорівнює одній четвертій,
помноженій на одну третю, і так далі.
Тут, до речі, є
кілька альтернативних способів записати тензорний
добуток двох векторів.
Коли ми використовуємо дірак-позначення і записуємо два кет-вектори поруч
ось так, це означає тензорний добуток.
Тому можна думати про тензорний добуток як про свого роду стандартний спосіб перемножити два стовпчикових вектори.
Не мало б сенсу
думати про добуток стовпчикових векторів ось так у термінах матричного множення, бо розміри не підходять,
тому тут насправді немає жодної проблеми
з неоднозначністю.
Ми також можемо записати
тензорний добуток ось так, всередині кет-вектора, і це означає
рівно те саме.
Це тензорний добуток
двох векторів.
Перший варіант дуже поширений, і насправді, мабуть, більш поширено записувати тензорний добуток ось так без символу тензорного добутку,
ніж включати символ. Другий варіант
значно менш поширений, але він іноді досить корисний, головним чином
як спосіб уникнути необхідності
в додаткових дужках у певних ситуаціях.
Ми також можемо виражати
тензорні добутки явно у термінах реальних стовпців з
числами, як бачиш тут,
якщо ми беремо тензорний добуток цих двох стовпчикових векторів тут, то ось вектор, який ми отримуємо,
і ти можеш бачити, що елементи тут є добутками елементів
цих двох векторів.
Порядок елементів
тензорного добутку узгоджується з
визначенням, даним хвилину тому, за умови дотримання угоди,
яку я описав раніше для впорядкування елементів
множин декартового добутку.
Дотримання цієї угоди еквівалентне тому, що
індекси першого вектора мають
більшу значущість, ніж індекси другого вектора,
тому можна бачити, що
переглядаючи елементи тензорного добутку, ми маємо всі добутки за участю першого елемента
першого вектора зліва,
яким є альфа один. Потім всі добутки
за участю другого елемента вектора зліва,
яким є альфа два, і так далі.
Ось приклад, де
вектор зліва має три елементи, а вектор
справа має чотири елементи, щоб ми краще
бачили, що відбувається.
WEBVTT
Ми маємо три елементи в першому векторі, тому спочатку записуємо три копії другого вектора, а потім множимо кожну з цих копій
на відповідний елемент
першого вектора ось так.
Вносимо альфи всередину ось так, і тут ми просто
множимо вектори на скаляри,
і нарешті прибираємо
дужки з копій і утворюємо єдиний стовпчиковий
вектор, як бачиш тут.
Як важливе зауваження, зверни увагу, що ми маємо такі формули для тензорного добутку
векторів стандартного базису.
Якщо ми беремо тензорний
добуток |a⟩ та |b⟩, що можна записати з
символом тензорного добутку або без нього, як бачиш тут,
то результатом є просто |ab⟩.
Якщо ми хочемо записати ab як впорядковану пару, а не рядок, ми можемо це зробити і отримаємо
цей вираз тут,
але значно частіше
записувати ось так, де ми прибираємо дужки,
але залишаємо кому.
У певному сенсі
той варіант з дужками, мабуть, більш коректний, але це досить стандартна
угода в математиці,
що дужки прибираються, коли вони не потрібні або не допомагають.
Можна думати про них як про неявні в цьому варіанті тут, і це просто менш громіздко
і приємніше на вигляд.
Тензорний добуток має
важливу властивість, яка полягає в тому, що він білінійний, а це означає, що він є лінійним
у кожному з двох аргументів, за умови, що інший фіксований.
Детальніше: він
лінійний в першому аргументі, що виражається цими двома рівняннями, які ти бачиш тут,
перше каже, що
якщо ми додаємо два вектори, Phi1 та Phi2, і потім беремо
тензорний добуток з Psi, ми отримаємо той самий результат, що й якби ми брали тензорний добуток
з Psi спочатку, а потім додавали.
Друге каже, що якщо
ми множимо деякий вектор Phi на деякий скаляр альфа, а потім беремо
тензорний добуток з Psi,
результат той самий, що й якби ми спочатку взяли тензорний добуток Phi та Psi, а потім помножили результат на альфа.
А також ми маємо лінійність
у другому аргументі, що є тим самим, але з переставленими ролями двох аргументів.
Ця властивість білінійності
досить легко перевіряється за визначенням, але добре записати її ось так, бо ми будемо часто
використовувати ці формули.
Зверни до речі увагу, що скаляри вільно проходять через тензорні добутки в сенсі, що виражається цими
рівностями тут.
Тобто немає різниці
між множенням першого аргументу на
скаляр альфа, в цьому випадку множенням другого
аргументу на цей скаляр,
та множенням всього
виразу на цей скаляр.
Ці рівності випливають з
цих двох рівнянь тут, і оскільки між цими векторами немає різниці, ми можемо просто записати
вираз, як бачиш тут,
без дужок, бо
вони не потрібні.
Вони не додають ясності
і не усувають неоднозначності, тому ми просто прибираємо їх і
отримуємо чистіший вираз.
Все це узагальнюється
до трьох і більше систем.
Ми можемо визначити тензорний добуток
трьох і більше векторів, узагальнивши формулу
для тензорного добутку двох векторів природним чином,
що можна побачити записаним тут. Кожен елемент тензорного добутку задається добутком відповідних елементів
векторів, тензорний добуток яких ми
беремо.
Рівнозначний спосіб
визначити тензорний добуток трьох і більше векторів
— зробити це рекурсивно, в кінці кінців спираючись на визначення
тензорного добутку двох векторів. Тому якщо n не менше трьох, ми можемо думати про
тензорний добуток n векторів
Phi1 до Phi n як про тензорний добуток між вектором, який ми отримуємо,
беручи тензорний добуток перших n мінус один
з них, та останнім вектором,
і якщо ти хочеш знати,
яким є тензорний добуток перших n мінус один векторів, ти або застосовуєш формулу
знову, якщо n мінус один
не менше трьох, або використовуєш визначення
для двох, якщо n мінус один дорівнює двом.
Два способи думати
про тензорні добутки трьох і більше векторів є рівнозначними.
Цього разу, коли ми маємо
три або більше векторів, тензорний добуток яких ми беремо, ми не використовуємо термін «білінійний»,
а натомість використовуємо термін «мультилінійний»,
але ідея та сама.
Тензорний добуток є лінійним
у кожній з позицій, за умови, що вектори в
усіх інших позиціях
зафіксовані. Переходячи до вимірювань
кількох систем в імовірнісних станах,
ми одразу отримуємо специфікацію того, як вимірювання
працюють для кількох систем, просто думаючи про них
колективно як про єдині системи,
за умови, що всі
системи вимірюються.
Для простого прикладу, припустимо, що ми маємо два
біти X та Y, і разом вони перебувають у цьому імовірнісному
стані тут,
який ми бачили раніше. Природно, якщо ми виміряємо
обидва ці біти, ми отримаємо результат 00,
тобто нуль при першому вимірюванні та нуль при другому вимірюванні, з ймовірністю одна друга, і ми отримаємо результат 1,1
WEBVTT
з ймовірністю одна друга теж. Це цілком зрозуміло.
По суті, вимірювання всіх систем рівнозначне вимірюванню
всієї складеної системи.
Якщо ж ми не вимірюємо всі
системи, а лише деякі з них, то ситуація не настільки
очевидна.
Обмежимо нашу увагу знову до випадку лише двох
систем, щоб побачити суть того, що відбувається, у якомога
простішому контексті.
Можна поставити таке запитання: припустимо, ми маємо дві системи X та Y, які разом перебувають як пара
в деякому конкретному імовірнісному стані.
Що трапиться, якщо ми виміряємо
лише X і нічого не зробимо з Y?
Що ж, ми можемо відповісти на це питання, використовуючи деяку базову теорію ймовірностей.
По-перше, ми знаємо, що ймовірність отримати певний результат вимірювання має задаватись цією формулою,
яку ти бачиш тут.
Ми можемо думати про ймовірності для кожного з класичних
станів пари XY, ніби ми дійсно вимірюємо обидва, і підсумовуємо всі ймовірності,
що узгоджуються з тим, що X перебуває в будь-якому класичному стані
a, який нас цікавить.
Ось чому сума тут береться лише за класичними станами b системи Y.
Один спосіб думати про цю
формулу — ймовірність побачити певний класичний
стан X, якщо ми його виміряємо,
повинна бути узгоджена з ймовірністю побачити цей стан, якби
ми також виміряли Y, навіть якщо ми цього не зробили,
це дуже природно та інтуїтивно. Ймовірність того, що вимірювання X дасть певний результат, може залежати від того, чи вимірювали Y
теж, незалежно від результату.
Отже, це говорить нам,
які ймовірності для різних можливих
результатів вимірювання, але що трапляється з Y або нашими
знаннями про Y у результаті?
Відповідь така: може все ще
існувати деяка невизначеність щодо стану Y у результаті вимірювання X
та бачення певного результату. І ця невизначеність представляється цією формулою тут для умовної ймовірності
того, що Y перебуває в деякому конкретному
класичному стані b, за умови, що X перебуває в деякому класичному стані,
в якому б класичному стані a
ми не виміряли.
Якщо бути точнішим, ймовірність того, що Y перебуває
в деякому класичному стані b, за умови, що X перебуває в класичному стані a,
дорівнює ймовірності
того, що X перебуває в a, а Y перебуває в b, поділеній на ймовірність того, що X
перебуває в класичному стані a.
Тому якщо ми вимірюємо X, ми побачимо
різні класичні стани з ймовірностями, що визначаються
цією формулою тут,
і залежно від того, який результат ми отримаємо, у нас може ще лишатись деяка невизначеність щодо класичного стану Y, і
ця невизначеність відображається
цією формулою тут.
Насправді є дуже простий
спосіб переформулювати все це та проводити обчислення
для конкретних випадків за допомогою дірак-позначення,
і він такий.
Ми починаємо із запису
імовірнісного стану XY у вигляді вектора ось так, і
це цілком загально.
Елементи позначаються Pab, і це можуть бути будь-які числа, аби весь вектор
був вектором ймовірностей.
Ми можемо виразити |ab⟩ як
тензорний добуток, як бачиш тут, а потім використати
білінійність тензорного добутку
і зокрема той факт, що він лінійний у другому аргументі, щоб виразити цей вектор,
як бачиш тут.
Фактично ми виокремлюємо вектори стандартного базису
у лівій частині та вставляємо те, що потрібно,
у правій частині,
щоб це дозволяло нам побачити, що відбувається, коли ми
вимірюємо першу систему X.
Зокрема, ймовірність
отримати певний результат a — це сума всіх ймовірностей, що з'являються
у дужках поруч з |a⟩.
І за умови отримання
певного результату a, вектор ймовірностей, що описує будь-яку невизначеність, що залишається щодо Y,
— це вектор, що був
у дужках поруч з a.
Крім того, ми повинні нормалізувати його, щоб зробити вектором ймовірностей, тобто потрібно поділити цей вектор
на суму елементів у цьому векторі, щоб утворити вектор ймовірностей.
Тут, до речі, сума береться за всіма
c в гамма, а не за b, просто щоб використати іншу назву змінної, аби не було плутанини
щодо областей видимості
змінних, так би мовити.
Суми в чисельнику
та знаменнику слід розглядати як окремі речі, і ми можемо уникнути будь-якої можливої
плутанини,
використовуючи різні
змінні для двох сум.
Ось швидкий приклад, щоб
проілюструвати, як все це працює.
Припустимо, XY — це пара бітів у цьому імовірнісному стані тут; щоб зрозуміти, що відбувається,
коли ми вимірюємо перший біт
і нічого не робимо з другим, ми записуємо вектор, як бачиш тут, де |0⟩ та
|1⟩ на першій позиції
виокремлені, як ми
описали кілька хвилин тому.
Перша можливість —
результат вимірювання нуль, і ймовірність
цього — сума ймовірностей
всередині дужок,
WEBVTT
що є тензорними до |0⟩. Тобто ми отримуємо одну дванадцяту плюс одну четверту, що дорівнює одній третині, і
за умови результату нуль
імовірнісний стан Y
стає цим вектором нормалізованим, або еквівалентно поділеним на ймовірність,
яку ми щойно обчислили, і тому ми отримуємо
цей вектор тут.
Друга можливість — результат вимірювання одиниця, і обчислення
проводиться аналогічно, використовуючи другий член у виразі,
а не перший. І якщо ти хочеш перевірити деталі, сміливо зупиняй відео, як завжди, щоб дати собі хвилинку для цього.
Ти можеш проводити такі ж
обчислення, щоб з'ясувати, що відбувається, коли
вимірюється Y, а не X.
Це той самий метод з урахуванням симетрії між двома системами.
Цього разу ми записуємо
вектор ймовірностей ось так, виокремлюючи вектори стандартного базису справа, як бачиш тут,
але в іншому все працює
абсолютно так само.
Ти також можеш використовувати цей метод
для більш ніж двох систем.
Це може бути трохи
громіздким, просто щоб записати всі необхідні вирази, але концептуально це
абсолютно та сама ідея.
Нарешті, для частини уроку
про класичну інформацію ми розглянемо операції
над імовірнісними станами
кількох систем, дотримуючись того ж міркування, яке ми тепер розглядали вже кілька разів.
Ми доходимо висновку, що імовірнісні операції над кількома системами схожі на
імовірнісні операції над одиночними системами, представлені
стохастичними матрицями.
Але цього разу ті матриці
мають рядки та стовпці, що відповідають декартовому добутку множин класичних станів окремих систем.
Тобто ми просто
розглядаємо складену систему, ніби вона є єдиною системою, та спираємось на опис того, як імовірнісні операції працюють
для одиночних систем, з
попереднього уроку.
Ось приклад операції, що називається операцією «контрольоване NOT»
над двома бітами X та Y.
Це насправді детермінована операція, і вона працює так:
якщо X дорівнює одиниці, то операція NOT виконується над Y,
а якщо X дорівнює нулю, то нічого не відбувається.
Біт X іноді
називається керуючим бітом, бо він визначає, чи
виконується операція NOT над Y,
а Y називається цільовим бітом, бо він — той біт, над яким виконується операція NOT.
Можна також уявити
обмін ролями X та Y, так що Y стає керуючим
бітом, а X — цільовим, але це інша операція,
ніж та, що описана тут, бо ця операція не є
симетричною між X та Y.
Обидві називаються
операціями «контрольоване NOT», і нам просто потрібно вказати,
який з бітів є керуючим і
який є цільовим.
Ця операція має дію,
яку ти бачиш тут, на стани стандартного базису, і ти можеш перевірити цю
дію за визначенням
операції. А ось матричне
представлення операції.
Коли ми думаємо про цю операцію, ми маємо на увазі, що є
ці два окремих біти, і вони відіграють ролі, які я щойно описав: X є керуючим бітом,
а Y є цільовим бітом, але насправді нічого
в цій дії тут або в цьому матричному представленні
не вимагає, щоб ми
думали про ці два біти як про окремі біти.
Ми могли б альтернативно просто
думати про цю операцію як про детерміновану
операцію над системою з чотирма класичними станами,
яким ми вирішили дати назви
0,0, 0,1, 1,0 та 1,1.
Ось ще один приклад
імовірнісної операції над двома бітами, яка не є детермінованою
операцією цього разу.
Операція встановлює Y рівним X з ймовірністю одна друга, а в іншому випадку навпаки: X встановлюється рівним Y.
Ця операція не має спеціальної назви, це просто приклад.
І ось матричне
представлення цієї операції.
Ти можеш бачити, що вона може бути виражена як середнє двох матриць: одна, що представляє детерміновану операцію,
де Y встановлюється на
значення, що зберігається в X, і інша, де
X встановлюється рівним Y.
Тут ми бачимо, що можемо брати середні значення стохастичних матриць для отримання нових — так само як ми мали в попередньому уроці.
Тепер розглянемо
таке питання. Припустимо, ми маємо дві
імовірнісні операції, кожна над своєю системою,
описані, як зазвичай, стохастичними
матрицями, і, щоб бути точними, припустимо, що M є
імовірнісною операцією
над системою X, а N є
імовірнісною операцією над системою Y.
Питання таке: якщо ми
одночасно виконуємо M над X та N над Y, як ми описуємо
ефект, який це чинить
на складену систему XY?
Думаючи про це
інтуїтивно, якщо ми одночасно
виконуємо дві операції над їхніми власними системами,
то ми фактично
виконуємо операцію над складеною системою, тому вона має описуватись
деякою стохастичною матрицею.
Коротка відповідь на це
питання полягає в тому, що матриця отримується шляхом взяття тензорного добутку, але не між векторами, як
ми говорили раніше,
WEBVTT
а між матрицями — в цьому
випадку матрицями M та N.
Тому давай приділимо кілька хвилин
обговоренню тензорних добутків матриць, а потім ми
повернемось до цього питання.
Ось визначення
тензорного добутку матриць, і воно
дуже аналогічне тензорному добутку векторів.
Якщо ми припустимо, що дві
матриці, з якими ми працюємо, записані у формах, які ти бачиш тут, так що елементи M
позначаються як альфа ab, де a та b
пробігають деяку множину класичних станів сигма, а елементи N позначаються бета cd, де c та d
пробігають деяку множину класичних станів гамма,
то добуток M та N є матрицею, яку ти бачиш тут.
Ми маємо щось схоже
на тензорний добуток векторів.
Рядки та стовпці M тензор N відповідають парам класичних станів, що записуються як рядки тут,
і елементи є добутками відповідних елементів M та N.
Ось ще один спосіб записати це в термінах окремих
елементів цих матриць.
Елемент ac bd матриці M тензор N є добутком елемента ab
матриці M та елемента cd матриці N.
Є ще один спосіб
описати M тензор N, а саме: це єдина матриця, яка перетворює будь-який вектор виду Phi тензор Psi
в тензорний добуток M застосованого до Phi з N застосованим до Psi, і це має бути справедливим для кожного вибору
векторів Phi та Psi.
Один спосіб думати про
це: тензорний добуток матриць чудово узгоджується з тензорним добутком векторів.
Це рівняння, яке
ти природно хочеш мати, і справді воно виконується.
В термінах матриць,
записаних явно, ми можемо визначити тензорний
добуток, як бачиш тут.
В цьому рівнянні є багато крапок, і вони мають
проілюструвати закономірність, яка є тією ж закономірністю,
що ми мали для векторів, тільки тепер ми маємо рядки та стовпці,
а не просто стовпчикові вектори.
Якщо це не цілком зрозуміло, може допомогти
такий приклад.
Тут ми говоримо про
тензорний добуток двох матриць розміром два на два.
Спочатку ми записуємо чотири
копії другої матриці — по одній для кожного елемента першої матриці.
Множимо кожну з цих
копій другої матриці на відповідний
елемент першої матриці,
і потім збираємо всe у
єдину матрицю розміром чотири на чотири, як бачиш тут.
Ми також можемо визначити
тензорний добуток трьох і більше матриць аналогічним чином, і, мабуть, найпростіший
спосіб виразити це
— ось так тут,
де ми маємо формулу для кожного елемента тензорного добутку, яка просто є добутком відповідних елементів.
Ти також можеш визначити тензорний добуток трьох і більше матриць рекурсивно в термінах тензорного
добутку лише двох матриць, так само як ми мали для векторів.
І остання примітка:
тензорний добуток матриць є мультиплікативним, що означає: добуток тензорних добутків
дорівнює тензорному
добутку добутків.
Про це можна думати
як про узагальнення формули, яку ми розглядали кілька хвилин тому, для дії тензорного
добутку матриць
на тензорний добуток векторів. І знову ж таки, це те, що
ми, звісно, хотіли б бачити справедливим, і ми можемо радіти, що так і є,
і будемо використовувати цей
факт, коли він нам буде потрібен.
І тепер ми можемо повернутись до
питання, поставленого раніше: як ми описуємо
ефект виконання операції M над системою X
та операції N над системою Y разом як операцію
над складеною системою XY?
І відповідь на це
питання полягає в тому, що дія описується
тензорним добутком M та N.
Тензорні добутки представляють незалежність, цього разу між операціями, на відміну від того, що ми бачили
раніше для векторів ймовірностей.
Ось швидкий приклад. Припустимо, ми виконуємо
імовірнісну операцію, описану цією матрицею, над бітом X.
Це операція, яку
ми бачили на першому уроці, і ми одночасно виконуємо
операцію NOT над бітом Y.
Комбінована операція над парою XY тому представляється тензорним добутком матриць, що відповідають цим двом операціям.
Ось та, що для X, і
ось операція NOT для Y, і ми отримуємо цю матрицю,
яку бачиш тут.
І ти можеш бачити, що справді
це стохастична матриця, і так буде завжди.
Тензорний добуток будь-яких
двох стохастичних матриць або будь-якої кількості стохастичних
матриць завжди буде стохастичним.
Дуже поширена ситуація —
коли одна операція виконується над однією системою, а з іншою системою нічого не робиться.
У такій ситуації ми дотримуємось абсолютно тієї ж схеми з розумінням того, що «нічого не робити» представляється одиничною матрицею.
Наприклад, якщо ми маємо два біти X та
Y і скидаємо біт X до стану нуль, що є тим самим
що виконання константної
функції нуль над X, і ми нічого не робимо з Y, то результуюча операція над парою XY
WEBVTT
представляється цим
тензорним добутком тут.
Все це узагальнюється
до будь-якої кількості систем, і ми побачимо деякі додаткові приклади, коли перейдемо до квантового контексту, що працює абсолютно так само,
за винятком того, що ми маємо унітарні матриці, а не стохастичні, і цього достатньо
про класичну інформацію наразі.
Тепер ми звернемо нашу увагу
до квантової інформації та того, як вона працює для кількох систем.
Схема та сама, що
і для класичної інформації.
Ми можемо розглядати кілька квантових систем як єдині складені системи та застосовувати те, що ми знаємо
з попереднього уроку.
Знову ж таки, тензорні добутки
відіграватимуть ключову роль, і загалом ми отримаємо опис того, як квантова інформація
працює для кількох систем,
що дуже схоже
та математично аналогічне до того, що ми щойно бачили для
класичної інформації.
Починаємо з квантових станів.
Квантові стани кількох систем представляються стовпчиковими векторами з комплексними числами як елементами
та евклідовою нормою, рівною одиниці,
так само як квантові стани
одиночних систем.
Цього разу індекси
квантово-статевих векторів відповідають декартовому добутку множин класичних станів
окремих систем,
бо знову ж таки, це
є множиною класичних станів складеної системи.
Наприклад, якщо X та Y — qubit-и, то множина класичних станів
пари XY разом є декартовим добутком двійкового алфавіту з самим собою,
що можна розглядати як
множину всіх двійкових рядків довжини два.
Тому ці вектори, що ти бачиш тут, — все це приклади векторів квантових
станів XY.
Якщо захочеш, можна альтернативно записати
ці вектори ось так, де ми маємо окремий кет для кожного qubit,
де тензорний добуток
між ними є неявним.
Або можна також записати
символ тензорного добутку явно ось так, якщо віддаєш перевагу.
І ще один варіант —
підписувати кети іменами систем,
які вони представляють, ось так.
І це можна робити з
символом тензорного добутку або без нього.
Це іноді може бути дуже корисним для збереження ясності.
Це просто різні стилі для вираження одних і тих самих векторів, і ми можемо обирати той, який хочемо, або якому надаємо перевагу, або який найбільш доцільний
для даної ситуації. Коли речі ускладнюються, наприклад, ми можемо вирішити, що один із
цих стилів додає ясності,
і ми вільні обирати
той, який хочемо.
Тензорні добутки квантово-статевих векторів теж є квантово-статевими векторами.
Для випадку двох систем, наприклад, якщо Phi є вектором квантового стану системи X, а Psi є вектором квантового стану
системи Y,
то тензорний добуток Phi та Psi є вектором квантового стану XY.
Стани на кшталт цього ми називаємо добутковими станами, і, аналогічно до того, що ми бачили в класичному імовірнісному контексті, вони представляють незалежність
між системами X та Y.
Тому, наприклад, якщо одна людина має лабораторію
в одному місці світу і вона створює систему X та ініціалізує її до квантового стану Phi,
а інша людина в
іншому місці світу незалежно ініціалізує систему Y до квантового стану Psi,
то якщо ми вирішимо думати про XY як про єдину систему, навіть якщо її дві частини знаходяться в різних місцях світу,
то складена система XY
перебуває в стані Phi тензор Psi.
Все це природним чином узагальнюється до
більш ніж двох систем.
Якщо ми маємо квантові
стани Psi1 до PsiN окремих систем X1 до Xn, то тензорний добуток цих n векторів
представляє квантовий стан, який знову ж таки називається добутковим станом складеної системи X1 до Xn.
Ось приклад квантового
стану двох qubit-ів.
Хоча спочатку може здатися, що це не так, це приклад добуткового стану, бо ми можемо записати
його як тензорний добуток, як бачиш тут.
Тому це приклад
добуткового стану незалежно від того, як він записаний; важливо те,
чи можливо записати його як тензорний добуток.
Проте цей квантовий стан, що знову є станом двох
qubit-ів, не є добутковим станом.
Він схожий за духом на
приклад, який ми бачили в імовірнісному контексті — два ідеально корельовані випадкових біти —
і той самий аргумент показує, що його не можна записати
як тензорний добуток.
Тому давай перенесемо це сюди і розглянемо аргумент трохи детальніше.
Уявімо, що ми
могли б записати цей стан як тензорний добуток
двох векторів Phi та Psi.
Елемент, що відповідає
класичному стану 0,1, дорівнює нулю для цього вектора, що ми можемо бачити просто подивившись на нього.
Проте це означало б, якби вектор був тензорним добутком двох векторів, що нульовий елемент Phi,
помножений на перший елемент Psi,
дорівнював би нулю, але це означає, що або
нульовий елемент Phi, або перший елемент Psi дорівнює нулю,
або обидва можуть дорівнювати нулю, але це суперечить тому факту,
що ці два добутки тут мають бути ненульовими.
WEBVTT
Вони дорівнюють одному
поділеному на корінь квадратний з двох. Аргумент насправді дуже
схожий на той, що ми мали в імовірнісному контексті.
Тут немає нічого суто
квантового взагалі.
Так чи інакше, ми виявляємо, що вихідний стан не є добутковим станом.
Зауваж, що не важливо,
що ці два числа тут є одним над коренем квадратним з двох.
Важливо лише те, що
обидва значення ненульові.
Цей конкретний квантовий стан
дуже цікавий. Це приклад
заплутаного стану двох qubit-ів.
Ми більше поговоримо про
заплутаність пізніше в серії.
Заплутаність може бути складною, особливо коли ми говоримо про квантові стани в загальній формулюванні
квантової інформації,
але тут, у спрощеному описі квантової інформації, заплутаність еквівалентна відсутності незалежності.
Тому для вектора квантового стану,
якщо він не є добутковим станом, він є заплутаним станом,
і цей конкретний стан
зазвичай розглядається як
архетиповий приклад заплутаного квантового стану.
І насправді ми іноді
думаємо про цей стан як такий, що представляє одну одиницю заплутаності, особливо коли ми думаємо про заплутаність
як ресурс, який можна
використовувати для цікавих речей.
Квантовий стан, про який
ми щойно говорили, є одним з чотирьох так званих станів Белла, які ти можеш бачити тут
разом з іменами,
що зазвичай використовуються для цих станів: Phi плюс, Phi мінус,
Psi плюс та Psi мінус.
Всі вони заплутані
і справді утворюють базис для простору всіх
векторів, що представляють стани двох qubit-ів.
Тому ці чотири вектори разом
називаються базисом Белла.
Це дуже поширена
колекція квантових станів, названих
на честь John Bell — фізика, який зробив
дуже важливий внесок
у вивчення заплутаності в 1960-х роках.
Ось кілька добре відомих прикладів квантових станів трьох qubit-ів.
Перший називається GHZ-станом.
Він схожий на стан Phi
плюс, який ми щойно розглянули, але для трьох qubit-ів замість двох.
А другий приклад називається W-станом і виглядає, як бачиш тут, — він рівномірний за
трьома двійковими рядками
довжини три, що мають
рівно один біт, встановлений на одиницю.
Жоден з цих станів не є добутковим, і обидва мають цікаві властивості та виникають досить часто як приклади, тому їх варто знати,
і ми ще побачимо їх.
Далі ми поговоримо про
вимірювання систем у квантових станах.
Дотримуючись того ж міркування,
якого ми дотримувались до цих пір на уроці, а саме — думати про кілька систем
як про єдині системи, — ми одразу приходимо до опису того, як вимірювання
кількох квантових систем працюють,
за умови, що всі
системи вимірюються.
Тобто якщо ми маємо деякий
вектор квантового стану Psi, що представляє квантовий
стан n-кортежу систем
X1 до Xn, і ми вимірюємо
всю складену систему, що еквівалентно вимірюванню
кожної окремої системи, то кожен можливий n-кортеж
класичних станів буде результатом вимірювання
з ймовірністю, рівною
квадрату абсолютного значення елемента Psi, що
відповідає цьому n-кортежу.
Наприклад, якщо ми маємо
пару систем XY у цьому квантовому стані тут, то якщо ми вимірюємо обидві системи,
то ми отримаємо результат «нуль червоних» — тобто нуль при вимірюванні X та червону при вимірюванні Y, —
з ймовірністю дев'ять двадцять п'ятих, і ми отримаємо результат «один пік» з ймовірністю шістнадцять двадцять п'ятих.
Це справді досить просто. По суті, ми просто ігноруємо той факт, що це дві окремі системи, і розглядаємо їх як
одну єдину систему,
але це підіймає
таке природне питання, яке ми вже розглядали
в класичному контексті.
Припустимо, ми маємо дві системи X та Y, що колективно
перебувають у деякому квантовому стані, і ми вимірюємо не обидві, а
лише одну систему.
Скажімо, ми вимірюємо систему X і нічого не робимо з Y.
Звичайно, ми також можемо запитати, що відбувається, якщо ми вимірюємо Y, а не
X, і більш загально — що відбувається, якщо ми маємо
три або більше систем
і вимірюємо деяку правильну їх підмножину. Але як тільки ми маємо відповідь на це питання, ми матимемо відповіді й
на ті питання.
Ми знаємо, що в загальному
вектор квантового стану пари XY має
форму, що ти бачиш тут, припускаючи, як зазвичай, що сигма та гамма
є множинами класичних станів
X та Y відповідно.
Елементи цього вектора
позначаються альфа ab, що пробігають всі можливі вибори a та b,
і вони можуть бути будь-якими комплексними числами, що роблять цей вектор
одиничним вектором.
Тепер ми вже знаємо, що якщо
обидві системи вимірюються, то ми отримуємо ймовірності для різних можливих результатів,
WEBVTT
беручи квадрат абсолютного значення відповідного елемента.
І тому якщо вимірюється лише X, то ймовірність
отримати певний результат a задається цим виразом,
ми просто підсумовуємо всі
можливі результати b, що могли б бути отримані,
якби Y теж вимірювали, хоча цього не відбулось.
Ідея та сама, що й
в імовірнісному контексті.
Ймовірність отримати
певний результат при вимірюванні X не може
залежати від того, чи вимірювали Y теж.
Тому це говорить нам,
які ймовірності для різних можливих результатів.
Крім того, відбудеться деяка
зміна стану Y в результаті виконання
цього вимірювання X та отримання певного результату.
Тому давай подивимось, як це працює.
Аналогічно до того, що ми робили в
імовірнісному контексті, ми можемо виразити
вектор квантового стану Psi, як бачиш тут,
де Phi a — це вектор для кожного вибору класичного стану a системи X,
ми використовуємо білінійність
тензорного добутку, так само як раніше.
Просто тепер ми вирішили назвати
ці різні вектори Phi a, просто для зручності.
Ми вже зазначили, що ймовірність того, що вимірювання дає
кожен можливий результат a, є такою, як бачиш тут,
але тепер ми можемо побачити, що ця ймовірність рівна квадрату евклідової норми вектора Phi a,
і тепер у результаті того, що вимірювання X дало певний результат a, квантовий стан
складеної системи XY
стає цим станом,
що ти бачиш тут.
Так само, як ми мали для одиночних систем, стан колапсує по суті, але він не колапсує
повністю в загальному,
він колапсує лише настільки, наскільки потрібно, щоб узгодитись
з тим, що вимірювання X дало результат a.
Квантовий стан Y стає нормалізованим Phi a, тобто ми
ділимо на його евклідову норму,
щоб він став одиничним вектором. Це аналогічно до того, що відбувалось в
імовірнісному контексті, де замість ділення
на евклідову норму
ми ділили на суму
елементів Phi a, щоб отримати вектор ймовірностей.
Але тут, оскільки ми
говоримо про квантові стани, ми ділимо на евклідову норму,
щоб отримати вектор квантового стану.
Давай розглянемо кілька прикладів, щоб побачити, як це працює
для конкретного стану.
Ось стан, який ми розглядатимемо. Ми припускаємо, що X та Y — qubit-и і вони перебувають у цьому конкретному стані Psi.
І припустимо, що X вимірюється.
Починаємо із запису
стану Psi, як бачиш тут, фактично виокремлюючи
множники стандартного базису X,
і тензоруємо їх з тим, що потрібно, щоб отримати вихідний стан.
Так само як у загальному
описі, що ми дали хвилину тому.
Ймовірність отримати результат нуль — це квадрат евклідової норми
цього вектора тут.
Те, що ми тензоруємо до |0⟩ в нашому виразі вектора Psi.
Тому ймовірність становить три четверті, і за умови
отримання результату нуль
квантовий стан
пари XY стає таким, де ми нормалізуємо
вектор, тензорований до |0⟩,
що еквівалентно
ділінню на квадратний корінь з ймовірності,
яку ми щойно обчислили.
Ми можемо потім спростити,
і ось що ми отримуємо.
Ймовірність отримати
результат вимірювання одиниця обчислюється аналогічно.
Ми беремо квадрат евклідової норми
цього вектора тут — те, що тензоровано до |1⟩ в нашому виразі Psi,
і результуюча
ймовірність становить одну четверту, що й повинно бути, звичайно, бо наші ймовірності
мають давати в сумі одиницю.
У цьому випадку квантовий стан XY стає таким, де знову ми нормалізуємо діленням на евклідову норму,
щоб отримати цей вектор квантового стану
як результат.
Той самий метод використовується
симетричним чином, якщо вимірюється Y замість X.
Ось вихідний вектор квантового стану, і цього разу, оскільки
вимірюється Y замість X,
ми виражаємо вектор Psi
як бачиш тут, де цього разу ми виокремлюємо
вектори стандартного базису Y,
а не X, тензоруючи
з тим, що потрібно, щоб отримати вираз для Psi.
Проходячи обчислення, що ти можеш перевірити,
зупинивши відео, якщо хочеш.
Ми бачимо, що ймовірність
отримати результат нуль становить вісім, і ось
вектор квантового стану,
що виходить за умови
отримання цього результату.
І ймовірність отримати
результат одиниця становить три восьмі, і в цьому випадку ось наш вектор квантового стану.
Ти можеш використовувати абсолютно той самий метод, якщо ти маєш більше двох систем і вимірюється будь-яка правильна їх підмножина.
WEBVTT
І є приклад
у текстовому матеріалі до цього уроку, який ти можеш
подивитись, якщо цікаво.
Коротко кажучи, ми завжди можемо розділити системи на дві окремі групи: ті, що вимірюються,
та ті, що ні.
І як тільки ми це зробили, ми спираємось на метод,
що я щойно описав, — і саме так працюють вимірювання для кількох квантових систем.
І тепер, нарешті, ми переходимо до унітарних
операцій над кількома системами.
Використовуючи ту саму базову ідею, що кілька систем можна розглядати як єдині складені системи,
ми доходимо до того, що ти бачиш
записаним тут на екрані: квантові операції над складеними системами представляються унітарними матрицями,
так само як ми мали для одиночних систем, і зокрема рядки та стовпці тих унітарних матриць відповідають декартовому добутку
множин класичних станів будь-якої сукупності
систем, про які ми говоримо.
Наприклад, якщо ми маємо систему X,
чиї класичні стани — один, два та три, і Y є qubit-ом,
то матриця, яку ти бачиш тут, є прикладом унітарної матриці, що представляє
операцію над парою XY.
Деталі того, як ми
впорядковуємо декартові добутки, про що ми говорили раніше, насправді не важливі
для цього прикладу; це просто матриця розміром шість на шість,
яка є унітарною.
Тут немає нічого особливого, хоча вона побудована з
кількох важливих матриць.
Суть у тому, що ти міг би
обрати будь-яку унітарну матрицю розміром шість на шість, і вона представляла б
унітарну операцію над XY.
Якщо ми застосовуємо набір
унітарних операцій незалежно, кожну над своєю системою, то їхня спільна дія
на складену систему задається тензорним добутком.
І тут на екрані ти можеш побачити більш точне
формулювання цього факту.
Якщо наші унітарні операції описуються унітарними матрицями U1 до Un — по одній для кожної з наших систем, —
то комбінована дія
на складену систему задається тензорним
добутком U1 до Un.
Знову ж таки, аналогічно до того, що ми мали в імовірнісному контексті, важливий приклад — коли ми застосовуємо деяку унітарну операцію
U до системи X і нічого
не робимо з деякою іншою системою Y.
Операція над XY, яку ми отримуємо, — це U тензоровано з одиничною матрицею.
Одинична матриця
описує «нічого не робити» з Y.
Іноді корисно явно написати, що ця одинична матриця
відповідає системі Y, просто щоб зробити формули чіткішими.
І один із варіантів —
дати одиничній матриці нижній індекс ось так, що вказує на систему, до якої вона застосовується.
Коли це достатньо зрозуміло, ми зазвичай не
турбуємось про нижній індекс, але коли речі ускладнюються, це може бути дуже корисним.
І ми також можемо розглянути
симетричний випадок, де деяка унітарна
операція V застосовується до Y і нічого не робиться з X,
і цього разу результуюча
унітарна операція над XY представляється цим
тензорним добутком тут.
І знову ж таки, ми можемо поставити нижній індекс на
одиничну матрицю, якщо це допомагає.
Ось кілька конкретних прикладів.
Якщо X та Y — qubit-и і ми
виконуємо операцію Hadamard над X і нічого не робимо з Y, ми отримуємо матрицю, яку бачиш тут.
Якщо ж, з іншого боку, ми виконуємо операцію Hadamard над Y і нічого не робимо з X, порядок тензорного
добутку змінюється на зворотній.
І тому ми отримуємо матрицю,
яку бачиш тут.
Не кожну унітарну операцію
над складеною системою можна виразити як тензорний добуток.
Якщо ми маємо тензорний добуток,
то маємо незалежність.
І є деякі досить
фундаментальні приклади операцій, які, звичайно,
не діють незалежно на кілька систем.
Наприклад, якщо X та Y мають
однакову множину класичних станів, якою може бути будь-яка
множина класичних станів сигма,
то ми можемо думати про
операцію обміну над парою XY.
Ця операція не змінює порядок двох систем — ми все ще маємо X
зліва та Y справа, — але вона представляє
обмін вмістом
двох систем. Ось це виражено
у формі рівняння, де ми маємо тензорний
добуток двох квантових станів.
Ще один спосіб записати це —
у вигляді матриці, як бачиш тут.
Думати про цей опис можна так: він говорить тобі, що відбувається для векторів стандартного базису.
І як тільки ми знаємо, що відбувається
для векторів стандартного базису, ми знаємо, що відбувається для
довільних квантових станів за лінійністю,
що насправді також справедливо для
цього виразу тут.
Тому ця конкретна операція тут є також детермінованою операцією, а також унітарною.
Якщо X та Y — qubit-и, наприклад, ми отримуємо це матричне
представлення тут.
Ось цікавий зв'язок
між операцією обміну та чотирма станами Белла, які показані тут для зручності.
Операція обміну залишає
перші три незмінними, але ставить знак мінус перед станом Psi мінус,
WEBVTT
тому в ньому є щось
особливе.
Ти можеш перевірити ці рівняння безпосередньо, подивившись на ці вектори та розглянувши, що відбувається
для станів стандартного базису:
обмін двох класичних станів для перших трьох станів Белла
нічого не змінює — ми отримуємо той самий стан, з якого почали.
У четвертому випадку, однак, знак мінус фактично
переходить від одного члена до іншого, коли ми виконуємо обмін класичних станів,
що еквівалентно множенню вектора на мінус один.
Тому виконання операції обміну якимось чином «виштовхує» знак мінус
з цього четвертого стану Белла.
Ми ще скажемо більше про
ці рівняння пізніше, але тепер перейдемо до
іншого типу операцій — контрольованих операцій.
Ми припустимо, що X — qubit, а Y — будь-яка система.
Якщо U є унітарною операцією над Y, то контрольована U операція над XY — це операція,
що виражена тут.
Спочатку з використанням дірак-позначення, а потім — того, що
називається блочною матрицею: уяви, що ти заповнюєш цю більшу матрицю
меншими, де ці нулі справді представляють матриці,
заповнені нулями.
Тобто кожен з цих чотирьох блоків представляє матрицю, що має
кількість рядків і стовпців, рівну кількості класичних станів Y.
Ідея контрольованої операції, з якою ми вже стикались
в класичному контексті, коли обговорювали операцію «контрольоване NOT»,
полягає в тому, що якщо X встановлено в нуль,
то з Y нічого не відбувається.
Але якщо X встановлено в одиницю,
то U застосовується до Y.
Тому X називається керуючим qubit-ом, а Y називається цільовою системою, яка в загальному
не обов'язково є qubit-ом.
Для конкретного прикладу,
який я щойно згадав, ми маємо операцію «контрольоване NOT».
Якщо перший qubit встановлено
в нуль, нічого не відбувається. А якщо перший qubit встановлено в одиницю, то виконується операція NOT, або рівнозначно,
операція сигма X
застосовується до другого qubit-а.
І ось його матричне представлення.
Ми говоримо тут про два qubit-и, тому ми могли б так само добре
вирішити, що другий qubit є керуючим, а
перший — цільовим.
Щоб описати цю операцію, ми просто міняємо порядок
в тензорному добутку, і результатом є матриця,
яку бачиш тут.
Якщо замість операції «контрольоване NOT» ми розглянемо «контрольоване сигма
Z», або «контрольоване Z».
Ми отримуємо це матричне
представлення тут. І для цього варіанту насправді не важливо,
який є керуючим, а який цільовим.
Ми отримуємо той самий результат в будь-якому разі.
Ми можемо йти далі і розглянути контрольовану операцію обміну.
І тут ми говоримо
про обмін двох qubit-ів, тому ми отримаємо три qubit-и, якщо включимо керуючий qubit.
Кожне матричне представлення
виглядає ось так.
Це досить особлива операція, і вона відома як операція Fredkin, або, частіше, gate Fredkin.
Коли ми думаємо про неї
як про gate в circuit, ми обговоримо circuit-и на наступному уроці.
Останній приклад — «контрольоване контрольоване NOT», що знову є
операцією над трьома qubit-ами.
І ось її матричне представлення. Ця операція набагато краще
відома як операція Toffoli, або gate Toffoli.
Ми обговоримо її детальніше
і побачимо, чому як вона, так і операція Fredkin є дуже важливими
операціями, на пізнішому уроці.
І це кінець другого уроку. На цьому уроці ми обговорили, як квантова інформація працює для кількох систем.
Сподіваюсь, ти приєднаєшся до мене
на третьому уроці скоро — він присвячений квантовим circuit-ам,
протоколам та іграм.
Бувай до тих пір.